[Music]
what anyone in this room described
themselves as argumentative stubborn
disagreeable and unemployed no stubborn
yes
none of those things [ __ ] you guys if
you believe it last one
oh no none of that [ __ ] if you want to
[ __ ] if you if you object [ __ ] he's
already are you okay I'm not [ __ ]
argumentative Oh [ __ ] coma - I will
never argue with you a new study has
found that drivers of flashy expensive
vehicles are jerks
thank God I don't have a flashy
expensive vehicle and BMW drivers right
dummy drivers no BMW Audi and another
Howdy's are flashy
it's the ultimate driving machine what
are these are [ __ ] chill out a
Mercedes and being the Magi the [ __ ]
cars whatever gets germans bro but BMW
divers Oh dicks
[ __ ] them I'm not in this I'm not in the
legit [ __ ] bitter yeah never I love
beer always dicks the old you weird [ __ ]
every time I get cut off it's a BMW
don't lose the real fast car I have one
and I don't drive it fast because it's
not a flashy fast car jerk ow d day
what about Chevy's what about real ones
are no one cares
I wonder what this do top is for a Chevy
girl you know the real fun chat you're
probably white trash you know the real
[ __ ] Prius with a new Nissan prism
Merry Christmas
I bet you there is a prismo and it's
like an Indian cars of name is mrs. Roth
ESMA G wagons are dicks - GUI GUI
like G wagons they [ __ ] you know what
I'm trying to I'm trying to just I'm in
the right lane also the G Wagen stops
dead in their tracks
turns on their emergency lights and
they're waiting for a parking spot in
the middle of the street oh the [ __ ]
dicks man okay so there's new study they
were saying that flat drivers of flashy
vehicles are less likely to stop and
allow pedestrians to cross the road with
the likelihood that they'll slow down
decreasing by 3% for every extra $1,000
that their vehicle is worth oh my maybe
because they know they can get out of
the way really fast because their cars
are capable no so it turns out that it's
because they seem to feel narcissistic
and like better than everyone else and
so they're just like my why would I stop
for you like let me [ __ ] what is
assumptions gonna be funny about the
comments section is that if they get
pissed then they're gonna be reinforcing
the stereotype so they can't say
anything exactly yeah okay I was cut off
last night by an Aston Martin not even
kidding right now an Aston Martin and it
was Tiger printed like look like [ __ ]
tiger print a West higher Brendan but it
was like yellow and black tiger print
now they ruin this beautiful car Leigh
oh it was gross whoever you are in
California with the tiger print did
Aston Martin your [ __ ] sounds like oh oh
a Russian oligarch or some [ __ ] [ __ ]
influencer that got a brandy or a rap is
she 13 year old kid [ __ ] are tick
tock killing it yeah I can't even drive
his car yeah so researchers they so the
way that they came up to this conclusion
is that they asked volunteers to cross
the sidewalk hundreds of times filming
and analyzing the response by car
drivers so researchers used one white
one black and one white and one black
man one white one black woman and so big
what about the yellow variety if that
asian people would try to run us over
yeah that's the opposite it's like the
slowdown it's a black guy Oh slow down
it's a white guy but maybe speed up I
don't know oh it's a you just run them
over that's the difference
what yeah
[Laughter]
people are driving to us Asian people
are driving toward Asian people to drop
to [ __ ] this is epidemic what you
gonna kill each other
yeah why do you think the traffic works
like this in Vietnam everyone's trying
to run each other over that's true I
knew that what know what he said oh I I
didn't hear the black and white people
were the pedestrians or the drivers
pedestrians are the people that are
trying to cross and so they would they
found that cars were more likely to
yield for the white and female
participants vehicle stop thirty one
percent of the time for both women and
white participants compared to twenty
four percent of men wait twenty four
percent of the time for men and twenty
five percent of the time for black
vehicle interiors that's what they found
and so because of that I might allegis
turn any of those numbers it's fine so
the point is the point is hot people you
can you're more likely to let the merge
in and [ __ ] right
well because I'm so captivated no these
are people the streets of pedestrians
and will you care about the more it care
about the women more than the men yeah
yeah but then twenty four percent of all
women in white men so anyway
not me I try to run everybody over
unless they're hot equally when I see a
mini scrub my school yeah in the middle
of the road oh sure should be driving
right now wow I wish it was
Taiwanese rules here because in Taiwan
it's the bigger the vehicle they have
the right of way is it really yeah so if
you're if you if you get hit by a truck
it's your fault for being in the way so
the big rig is like good luck everybody
else yeah that regular like I guess
humanity was not trying to run people
over but if you're a smaller car get the
[ __ ] out of the way it makes more sense
because we're the opposite the
pedestrian has the right-of-way it could
be like a pileup of cars like 50 cars
but the pedestrian wants to stand there
dude I saw it I saw a Twitter video of a
bunch of people like blocking a road to
protest some [ __ ] yeah and a trucker
just [ __ ] drives all the way through
them Oh God I mean they moved around it
Bailey just in time but the targeted
give a [ __ ] cheese yeah I like that yeah
it was funny because nobody I hurt okay
then it's funny
I'm laughing Arctic I'm glad there
wasn't one hero like now I'm not gonna
stand for this and then they stand and
got run over nobody will stand for
anything while a truck is [ __ ] coming
out I'm day long.you you gotta be stupid
to do that yeah yeah that's what the
trucker was counting on and he was right
right so more facts and there was this
other survey of 1892 drivers by the
University of Health Helsinki Helsinki
pulsing giggles thank you thank you okay
it's up babe those they deemed to have
more just those that deemed to have more
disagreeable character traits were more
drawn to high status cars like a big
mole oh why did I picture a giant animal
when you said that weighted Bart's brain
go right now but it was my brain I
pictured a ball about as big as a
bookcase giant animal will be a part of
this but I was open to him yeah so they
said that the ones that were more likely
to run a red light not give way to
pedestrians and generally drive
recklessly and too fast were often the
ones driving fast German cars is with
this health ache a BMW a German the
stereotype right is that a guy with a
flashy car has a car because he's
insecure about himself so he's trying to
like show and prove both you know this
guy's but no matter what it is both yeah
like well actually small car or big ass
truck because he's trying to show off
that either like he has money or he's
like you need some most love front yeah
because he's never received because I
come really quickly right but ya know
earlier today I was watching this one
video who is it you send it to me like
what does he do philosopher I don't know
the point is he was saying that people
that end up like what you're saying like
guys who have really expensive flashy
cars is that most likely and
they're also drawn to like high-end
brands and like expensive things that
they need to shower themselves with is
because they need validation that they
didn't have when they were growing up so
they seek it through money or like
through getting it from the world like
everyone else looking at them and saying
oh they have money like they they're
seeking that type of validation so in
reality these people they just really
really need validation that's not the
reason why I like Kirkland I'm not
trying to give out this from anybody I
just
I'm a big fan of Kirkland I that's a
high-end brand I love Kirkland yeah what
about cars though it's the Kirkland the
cars is that Chevy think it is I think I
like the ROC characteristic of Chevy Oh
with the eyebrows yeah I've heard of
that no this it's like a rock rock Oh
Dwayne Johnson is what I was thinking of
is your brain I've heard of that too but
I don't think it's a it's a general
truth it's it depends on the individual
if they're if they're seeking validation
outwardly or if someone's content with
their life and then they just like
things it could get confusing because
you can judge a person based off of the
things that they own or have right so
for example of the study was done mainly
on people from poverty-stricken nations
and they tend to like extra [ __ ] like if
you've seen like that new money like
people right they like LV print [ __ ]
everything their homes look like a
[ __ ] Cathedral like it's super gaudy
[ __ ] and we call that tacky or whatever
but they're just overcompensating for
all the things that they didn't have and
when they grew up their neighborhood was
like full of bullet holes and garbage
and everything so then they want the
opposite everything being top-notch yeah
I mean I think we all do that when we go
up kind of broke you know like when I
even when I was least in the Maserati
for a few years like I remember like
yeah but I got a good deal people didn't
know it was like as cheap as it was but
you got to have nice [ __ ] but then feel
great about it cuz you got a deal like
it would get exactly like it and it was
definitely you know it felt good to like
get compliments about the car and get
looks and [ __ ] but after a few years of
it I was like I think I've done it
enough you know I think I don't need to
I don't need to pull up in the Maserati
more like attention release channel when
I see me for my mom you get more
attention from boys when you have a
sports car than anything hi girls don't
even give a [ __ ] dude they're like
that's cool I haven't homie that drives
a pretty flashy car but he totally does
it to show off cuz um I was in his cars
at night and I'm people were people were
staring right and he's like at first
he's kind of like oh he's got a staring
it and I was and he was like oh the car
of course and then I was like and he
thought maybe it's cuz they recognized
him cuz he does stuff too and I was like
wait your windows are tinted right and
he's like actually they're not
I like okay then obviously you're trying
to get recognized if you got these super
expensive car and your windows are
[ __ ] not tinted at all people with
them having their their blinds wide open
at night like why Brad Pitt having a
license plate this is Brad Pitt yeah I
had a buddy he was like my best friend
and he bought a PT Cruiser and I never
talk to him again
wait you're [ __ ] man I remember those
were popular for like are they still
around oh they look like the monster
cars they look like a like Transylvania
yeah I get so mad just seen a PT Cruiser
especially if I'm behind one I got so
[ __ ] this is that the midlife crisis
car no no that's like a giant of a
prowler it's like oh well I've seen the
PT Cruiser the convertible one I thought
all of these guys wait did you the
convertible PT Cruiser how [ __ ] dare
they PT Cruiser like a grandma's farm
Iceland Plymouth yeah looks like it's a
Christmas
it's a Prisma guys this I could have
sworn I actually made it forward oh my
god that would be the ugliest thing ever
[ __ ] nevermind I'm not thinking about
that I'm thinking about the Chrysler I
think about the Plymouth Prowler yeah
you're you're thinking optimistically
yeah and I'm over here on the PT Cruiser
level that looks like a cool car don't
say that don't say that